las exigencias de moscú no han sido
escuchadas por washington y sus aliados
ese fue el mensaje enviado por el jefe
de la diplomacia rusa también est
contiene una reacción que nos permite
esperar que se inició un diálogo serio
pero sobre las cuestiones secundarias en
cuanto a la cuestión principal no hay
ninguna reacción positiva en el
documento la cuestión principal es
nuestro claro mensaje de que
consideramos inaceptable una mayor
expansión de la otan hacia el este y el
despliegue de armas que pueden amenazar
a la federación rusa de vostok
ayer eeuu y la otan rechazaron como era
de esperarse la principal demanda rusa
el fin de la política de ampliación de
la alianza atlántica- una decisión bien
recibida por kiev en otras palabras
moscú quiere evitar a toda costa que su
vecino se convierta en miembro del
bloque algún día representantes rusos y
ucranianos se reunieron el miércoles en
parís unos debates con la mediación de
francia y alemania- ambas partes se
comprometieron de nuevo a respetar el
alto al fuego en la región del donbass
pero no hubo otra clase de progreso se
espera otro encuentro en febrero si la
buena noticia es que los consejeros han
acordado o reunirse en berlín dentro de
15 días lo que significa que al menos
durante las próximas dos semanas es
probable que rusia se mantenga en la vía
diplomática
preocupado por una posible escalada
militar el gobierno de joe biden ha
instado a sus ciudadanos a considerar
salir de ucrania ahora mismo y ha
advertido que el oleoducto norte windows
entre alemania y rusia no avanzará de
haber una invasión en paralelo un debate
entre manuel marco y vladimir putin está
previsto para este viernes